schetagne a dû mais on soupe en famille
tous les soirs au rituel sacré qui a dû
être mis de côté pendant trois semaines
fin octobre
l'enseignant d'éducation physique tombe
malade deux jours après avoir appris que
ses élèves avaient contacté l'aco vide
elle passe immédiatement un test de
dépistage
je me doutais qu'elle est positif
l'envoi embarque un petit peu j'avais
peur que ça dégénère que je suis obligé
de me rendre à l'hôpital quelques larmes
vers la famille enfin toute la famille
doit se confiner à la maison son
conjoint ses trois enfants vont se faire
tester eux aussi daniel va s'isoler au
sous sol qui est rebaptisé la zone rouge
avec j'ai été positive ma fille qui a sa
chambre seul et tu te dis maman je te
donne ma chambre
vosu seul comme ça nous on a le cas de
la maison pour nous deux jours plus tard
megan va la rejoindre la fillette de 8
ans est elle aussi atteinte de l'aco
vide contrairement à sa mère elle est
asymptomatique
c'est un aspect très positif dans la vie
en général donc ça bien été elle avait
emmené des jeux de société des casse
tête à la baie à ce que bien seul au six
voyages et troisième lectures rabin
quand des vrais pendant ce temps il y en
ait de son fils à faire ces travaux
scolaires
l'organisation familiale repose sur ses
épaules
mon copain au lui ai travaillé fort tous
veulent aller faiblira pas le suivi
scolaire des deux plus grands tout en
étant télétravail
oui alors que tania et mégane s'apprête
à quitter la zone rouge et que la
famille il voit enfin la lumière au bout
du tunnel
coup de théâtre j'allais mettre du
purell puis d'habitude pour l accent
très fort puis je me suis rendu compte
que cette fois ci ils sentaient moins
forme ou pas du tout jade est la
troisième contracté l'aco vide
l'adolescente doit rester à l'écart
pendant dix jours
le conteur repart à zéro pour yann et
antoine pour mon conjoint est mon fils
le 14 jours d'attendre parce que
lorsqu'on est négatif 7 14 jours de
confinement donc recommencer à chaque
fois je pense que c'est moi qui a
contaminé mais mes deux filles
le coc vide va chambouler la vie
familiale pendant 23 jours et pendant le
match on n'a que ça finisse qu'il y
avait tout un autre tiers embarqué
partout au québec des milliers de
familles vivent le même genre de
situation le coronavirus c'est aussi
infiltrés dans la maison d'isabelle
desgagnés à la 6e 6e journée d'isolement
la mère de famille de roberval nous
envoyer des vidéos pour raconter son
quotidien est tombé de la maison carrée
mais je ne porte pas si l'idéal une
idole dans ma chambre j'ai mon kit
coville je l'appelle mon refus de kobe
dans ma chambre quand elle va la salle
de bains elle doit tout désinfecter
elle est la seule atteintes de lakovic
et l
son conjoint ses deux filles ont dû
s'adapter à cette nouvelle réalité
au départ sa fille aînée réagit mal
parce qu'elle s'inquiète comme ça qui
compte et combat bon taux longs qui
soient négatifs ou belle qu'on le prenne
en rien qui contraignent comme un jeu
[Musique]
elle a beau être sous le même toit
isabelle se sent souvent loin de sa
famille des fois avec classe et même si
l'aco vide n'a pas été catastrophique
pour les familles de tania du met et
d'isabelle desgagnés elle va laisser des
traces
le plus difficile c'est de vivre dans la
crainte que ma femme et mes enfants
gardent des séquelles de ce vélo sur
l'essoufflement donc je monte un
escalier je passe l'aspirateur je dois
prendre des pompes pour l'asthme j'ai
une douleur dans la poitrine avec ses
symptômes qui persistent tania n'est
toujours par retourner au travail
[Musique]
quant à isabelle elle a pu sortir de son
isolement et enfin retrouver ses deux
filles tout ça énorme quand que
finalement ce lot c'est malgré tout nous
on était chanson n'a pas eu besoin
d'hospitalisation n'a pas eu besoin de
mes salengro infractions la vie vraiment
en attendant de retrouver la forme
tania se console en se disant que ses
proches eux ont pu revenir à leur vie
normale
[Musique]